bonjour je suis mariée talleroux VH de
Holcim outremer vous êtes ici dans les
locaux ou sur le site de Sim à la
Réunion pour le ciment c'est un groupe
de 70 000 personnes présents dans 70
pays et ici à la réunion nous avons
quatre activités le ciment le granulat
le béton et l'activité de précontrain à
la réunion nous comptons 200
collaborateurs un peu plus de 200
collaborateurs et il y a environ 50
métiers qui sont représentés ici on y
trouve aussi le siège de holcimoutramer
aussi outremer c'est Maurice Madagascar
et la Réunion
nous recrutons aujourd'hui deux
techniciens de maintenance
un en mécanique et un électricité en
termes de profil on recherche quelqu'un
qui a un bac + 2 et qui a du potentiel
pour évoluer c'est d'abord et avant tout
un futur collaborateur qui respecte nos
valeurs j'en citerai d'eux
l'intégrité très importante et
l'orientation client donc pour un
technicien de maintenance l'orientation
client son client c'est la production
son client est le plus souvent interne
on recherche avant tout pour des
techniciens de maintenance des personnes
vraiment engagées motivées
disponible des personnes qui sachent
travailler en équipe qui pourront
évoluer dans un groupe comme l'autre il
doit évoluer aussi sur des pannes donc
là il faut qu'il soit très réactif pour
dépanner rapidement l'usine pour
satisfaire notre client qui est la
production
le technicien de maintenance doit
contrôler surveiller et entretenir
régulièrement les équipements
anticiper les pannes
dépanner et optimiser l'outil de
production
maîtriser l'informatique industrielle
et faire preuve d'une grande capacité
d'adaptation